هو المساعده العسكريه طلبها دم بن دواس من
الامام محمد بن سعود فكان ايضا الامام
محمد بن سعود لديه تطلع ايضا في محاوله
لملمه ايضا هذه الظروف المحيطه ايضا
الجوانب الامنيه وايضا مد السيطره على هذه
المدينه الرياض وهذا التي تحقق الحقيقه
بالتالي عندما اوظن ولعل هذا يذكرنا ايضا
بفكره ايضا جد الاسره السعوديه ابراهيم بن
موسى بن ربيعه عندما كان يتحاول ان يمتد
شمالا وايضا ان يقضي على ايضا الخصوم في
الجهات الشماليه في القرن العاشر الهجري
وتوسع ايضا في في تلك الناحيه فالمقصود
انه قضيه ايضا محمد بن سعود في جزء من هذه
الامور انه يريد ايضا ضبط وايضا علاقات
تقويه ايضا علاقاته الجانبيه ايضا في
المدن القريبه وايضا مد ايضا الامر او
العامل الامني الذي يريد ان ينظر له